my show MRE is the number one show in
Las Vegas we bring in $150 million into
the casino a year I've done over 5,000
shows in Vegas I've been performing here
since 2005 but do you love doing a
residency versus like doing a world tour
it's a job you know I had the
opportunity one time to have dinner with
Elton John and he said Las Vegas
audience is the toughest audience
because they're coming in they're seeing
you then they're doing this then they're
seeing that person then they're going
out to a club lots of things to do but
when you tour it's an event the radio
was talking about it people are driving
6 hours to see steo and I've never
missed a show since I've been in Vegas
because when I had nothing I couldn't
even afford to rent a car and I walked
to go see the show that I bought tickets
for and it was cancelled I was so pissed
I spent the money on the plane ticket on
the hotel I just promised myself that if
I was ever blessed and fortunate enough
to have success that I would never
cancel mind freak is a great show and
I'll be doing it 200 times a year